hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom livestream very excited about
the conversation we're about to have I
will start with my standard announcement
to remind everyone that we are a
not-for-profit organization and we can
only exist with support from donors like
yourself I do want to give a special
shout out to several corporations and
partners that have stepped up in the
last few weeks especially when they
realized we were running into deficit
even before kovat and that deficit
larger as we tried to have higher surfer
capacity and more programs so special
thanks to Bank of America google.org 18t
fastly and Novartis and I just reminder
we continue to run into deficit so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about making a donation to Khan
Academy so that we can serve many many
tens of millions of more for it for a
long time to come with that I'm really
excited our next guest Fareed Zakaria he
is a well-known host in CNN's GPS a
Washington Post columnist author and I I
would like to say good friend and mentor
of myself and you know I think what's
we're so good to see you for either if
you can hear me I can hear you cell it's
a little bit jerky but I think we're all
getting used to life with zoom which I
have to confess this not doesn't work as
well as the Khan Academy website I don't
know if that's a veiled compliment or
not well thanks for joining and you know
when we when we schedule these things
you know there was already a lot going
on in the world and obviously things are
just layering on top of it you know I
would love to just get your just raw
take of well what how are things going
for you personally but just what's your
sense of what the world is like you know
you're in New York you're
you know you know what do you think the
covert layer is about what do you think
the economic layer is about and now what
do you think the the the kind of police
brutality racial systemic racism layer
is all about right now oh my gosh that's
a big girl so big ask but so let me try
and do it it feels to me like at the
very start it became clear to me and I
wrote this of the week the you know
Kovac kind of exploded that this was
going to be a series of kind of
cascading crises because we had never
seen anything quite like this because
you first have the pandemic we realize
okay we're in a genuine global pandemic
and you don't have a lot of actual
global pandemics you know SARS MERS
these were regional they never spread so
this is really the first thing we have
experienced where it really am
interested I'm sure you've noticed the
cell when you call somebody in India
Bangladesh you know you talk to somebody
in Korea you talk to somebody in Europe
they're all had dealing with exactly the
same thing that you know there's a
strange sense which been United around
this this disease then you had the
second extraordinary thing which is
historically totally unprecedented which
is we induced economic paralysis in
basically most of the most richest
countries in the world seventy-five
percent of the global economy went into
a lockdown nobody has ever done anything
like this before that's why the numbers
we were seeing you know frankly in terms
of the ski the speed and scale dwarfed
even the Great Depression because even
with the Great Depression it took years
to get to the unemployment numbers that
we got to within weeks so you've got
that layer then I think we are now going
through the third layer which is the
widening inequality of the response so
the rich world is able to deal with this
because they can print money rich
countries can borrow essentially you
know in an unlimited fashion
China the United States Germany United
States above all really has the the
ability to print money because it has
you know kind of sovereign capacity like
nobody else and so while everyone's
uneasy about it you can do a lot I mean
the United States did in three weeks
what it did in a 809 in three years and
it was probably going to do more but
then you get to the part of the world
what you can't do that and you're
beginning to see that now with the
India's the Brazil's the you know all
these places where the disease is
spiraling they cannot lock down any
longer large part of the economy is day
labor which means people make the money
that they spend the money bad day on
food right so you're dealing with that
kind of site and then you add to it the
protests which I think are not unrelated
I mean I think you've got you know in
the United States forty million people
on unemployed nothing to do watching
this brutality on television and I say
you know I mean there's there's what
does all this do it produces nervousness
anxiety a sense of purpose lessness
despair and then against that you have
the you know in America in America's
case the oldest story in America the oh
the great dis tragedy in American
history playing out one more time
so I think you know that's the
trajectory now personally you asked I
gotta confess for me it hasn't been a
big deal I'm lucky I have a large family
so I've got three kids you know I forget
I've gotten to see my kids more than I
have been able to for a long time my son
is back from Yale my daughter's back
from boarding school my little one is
here I've got a job which I can do
reasonably well you know where I think
about 90% of technological capacity and
110 percent of intellectual capacity
just because it's so interesting and so
engaging I've been working on a book
that's easy to do from anywhere you know
I miss real life but I've been able to
cope just fine and and where do you see
this going I mean and and first
you did a great job we covered all of
those layers but where do you see this
going you know where do you see I mean
there's really two layers that you've
been you're talking about that I think
are really interesting one is that
disparity between the rich and the poor
countries and you know it seems like
your point the you know I've been
studying this myself it seems like the
u.s. doesn't almost this infinite
capacity to print money and and then
bought you know then the fact the the
the federal government could borrow the
money and distribute it and it seems
like there and we could talk about what
the implications are other countries
can't and then separately you have
people who are angry rightfully angry
about what they are seeing in the world
and it still has not changed and there
is probably an economic aspect that it
could morph into I guess taking one at a
time maybe the latter one first where do
you see the the the protests evolving to
do you think it's going to be you know
hey here this is how you have to reform
police training and this and that you
think it's gonna stay to that everything
is going to expand into other things
here's the ulema I mean this is at some
level the oldest story in American
history which is the story of the way in
which blacks have uniquely been been
treated badly by the American system
from the Constitution into which they
were written into slavery 250 years
working without pay in the most brutal
dehumanizing conditions their families
broken up a hundred years of Jim Crow
then mass incarceration but there's
another piece of it as you say which is
really about the police and the way the
police you know
handle things and they've come together
we have a police force that frankly
looks more like an army in most cities
it behaves more like an army in most
cities it's totally outside of the
black-white issue it's a problem so I
think that the the the the problem for
the United States is this you can
marshal the anger and the and the
movement for something like this
at a national level very well Martin
Luther King did it totally brilliantly
but he was asking his ask was a national
ask the civil rights bill fair housing
the ask here is that 18
housing police departments you heard
that right there are 18,000 police
departments in America have to reform
themselves and create different rules
that allow for you know bad police to be
to be penalized frankly to recruit a
different kind of policeman in many
cases how are you gonna do that I don't
quite understand you know so I think
that and part of the frustration here I
think has then that people have seen
look we've been we've been hearing good
stuff from that from the national
leaders for a while now every time
something like this happens everybody
agrees this is awful we need to do
something about it but you have that
national unanimity or agreement or
consensus and somehow it doesn't trickle
down it doesn't translate into a
difference in the day to day live
experience of an African American and
and this is why because you know most of
that is about local police chief's local
DA's judges who are often elected so you
need you know we need a kind of a
different model where you take this
passion and so directing it at
Washington and Trump God knows he
deserves it but it's not gonna make any
difference you know what you need to do
is at a very local level and you do you
think that's going to be effective you
think it's going to happen and obviously
it could be on the police reform
dimension it could be on the general
criminal justice reform dimension or it
could be at the systemic racism which is
a much broader notion dimension you you
think do you think it's great this time
is different or or will the frustration
just you know continue in three years
from now we're back back to where we
were where people are angry because
something like this happens again I hope
something happens but I think it's gonna
be hard in the short term because to
sustain this kind of intensity of effort
at the local level requires that people
stay mobilized at the local level which
they have not tended to be so then you
would need a push from the federal
government from really the president
clearly Trump is not that president he's
not going to be the guy pushing this so
maybe if you had a different president
if you had you know different you you
need some process because what you know
the crowds go away the police unions
stay you know what I mean
the forces that our obstacles are very
powerful local and French forces the the
the passion of the moment cannot be
maintained this is what King was
brilliant about he had he figured out a
way to channel that passion and to stand
and he use it effectively at strategic
moments and so you need is something
like that at the local level and the
problem is you need 18000 of those those
movements you know yeah no and I don't
encourage anyone on watching on Facebook
or YouTube please send in your your
comments you know going into that the
economic layer here's a question from
Facebook Shoaib Mohammed asks what will
the future look like in terms of
economic economic point of view and then
from Facebook these are related Fred
Adler editor asks do you believe
universal basic income would help yeah
what are your thoughts are there I mean
how will this be a minor it looks like
the stock market thinks that you know
nothing happened
no yeah how do you think's gonna play
out so with the stock seems to suggest
and look you know stock market can also
be right today and then wrong tomorrow
experience that but if there's a message
here it is don't fight the most powerful
central bank in the history of the world
you know there's no you cannot fight the
Fed the Fed yes said that they might you
know buy bonds they might back junk
bonds they might buy stocks I mean the
Fed is basically saying we have infinite
capacity and we are willing to use it on
essentially infinite assets where there
is no asset that we regard as being off
limits for us in that circumstance how
could an asset go down right I mean you
have to be the the floor of the most
powerful central bank in the world
saying we're not gonna let this collapse
well that's a wonderful you know casino
game to play which is heads I win tails
the Fed Muslims and the Fed can't lose
you're fine so I don't know how how long
can the Fed continue to do that I mean
in a way it's a kind of it's a it's
changing the rules of capitalism right I
mean as the sense in which you wonder if
you have you have lectures on this what
does price discovery mean anymore
in a
whether you say yeah you know there are
markets that prices rise and fall but if
they if things get too bad the Fed will
step in so you have this kind of floor
do we ever for example do we ever need
to have a recession again if the Fed
says we'll just you know we will protect
the downside so that's a meta meta
question short-term there's no question
the United States comes out if that's
the best of all the countries in the
world because of the same reason it came
out of the overweight crisis the best of
all the countries in the world I mean
people forget we created we caused the
financial crisis the global financial
crisis it was the irresponsibility of
some combination of the private sector
and the public sector in the in America
that did it who came out of it best
without any question in the United
States our banks are more dominant in
the world than they were before the
famine it's the most extraordinary thing
the banks which were supposed to be the
origin of this problem are now more
powerful you know globally than they've
ever been before
America's five biggest banks have larger
market share than anyone so there's a
long-run question of Ken Ken you know
the article in foreign affairs that says
can you print me can you have magic
money forever I don't know the question
that nobody knows the question to that I
remember when when Japan crossed the 75%
debt to GDP ratio people said this is it
there's no country has ever done
anything like this you know this is
wearing uncharted borders this is going
to cause huge problems for Japan Japan
is currently at 250 percent debt to GDP
ratio so you know maybe that's maybe
something you a small number of
countries can do I think the most
important thing to remember is you know
India can't borrow like that turkey
can't borrow like that Brazil can't
borrow like that they borrow a short
term debt in in in dollars which means
they have to pay it back and if their
currency depreciates then I have to pay
more so that's that's very tough um so I
think for the u.s. the big part that I
don't think has been fully factored in
by the market is this is going to be a
very slow halting recovery I mean
there's you know you're not going to
have a crash and a collapse because of
the Fed but the Fed can't can't force
people to go to
you know to fly the Fed can't force
people to go to restaurants it can't
force them to go to movie theaters that
are empty it can't force the NFL to
start holding games so that all that
spending is not going to take place now
the simplest principle of economics is
my spending is your income so if
spending is down how can you know how
can the economy be anything but at a
much lower capacity you know China is
finding that they thus your production
is up to 90% of pre-crisis but
consumption is not even up to 50% so the
Chinese are now trying to give free gift
certificates one I think to billion
dollars of literally you know like
imagine getting those you know getting
coupons on the street which you can you
can just spend it retail as a way of
inducing expenditure I mean I wonder
whether that's what we will have to deal
with because we're not at the basic
universal basic income uh that's kind of
solving a different problem which is
technology and automation globalization
making so large numbers of people don't
have enough to do and can't make enough
money well we have right now the problem
is we just can't get people to spend
money because what do they do they can't
take a vacation they can't get on an
airplane they can you know so how do you
force that how do you force expenditure
into the system yeah that's super
helpful
you know for those watching I remember
growing up I was always confused if
people talk about central bank's print
money where does the money go and to
just you know double click on that what
what freeze describing is the center
especially the Federal Reserve of the
United States which is quasi independent
but really governmental institution can
essentially print money where does it go
it goes and buys assets normally it buys
government debt so it's essentially
lending money to the federal government
the more it does that the cost of the
debt goes down and but now it's buying
almost everything this is what freed
saying but and so you could imagine as
the cost of debt goes down then the
federal government can borrow more and
more and more and do these trillion
dollar at a time stimulus and at the
same time the Federal Reserve could get
more aggressive and buy debt from
companies maybe even one day think about
buying things like equities and and be a
Florida the more
kid but you know there's an interesting
question there your point you know maybe
the Fed could engineers at least the
mock the market has afford to it and and
certain parts of the economy you know
the debt markets but that benefits and I
think we saw this coming out of the
financial crisis it benefits homeowners
you can refinance and your mortgage goes
down it benefits people who have 401ks
in stock and shareholders so but that's
the people I've just described are the
more well-off already what happens to
you know this kind of mate I don't fits
universal basic income or this you know
a gift certificate type program what
happens to the people who are waiters
and waitresses small restaurant owners
you know air be and being their house
and you know on a small scale that how
do they live is not an obvious question
and not an obvious answer yeah so that's
a that's a that's like the broader the
bigger question just one factoid which I
think would be it would be helpful for
you to understand so everything you said
of course about the Fed is exactly right
now keep in mind because of all the
factors you were describing the federal
government is currently borrowing at
point eight percent so think about all
you homeowners who have managed to
refinance heroically at three point two
five well three point five the
government is boring at zero point eight
percent
10-year bonds so at some level it's very
sensible for it to be borrowing the
money as long as it spends it on useful
things I mean that's the part which I've
always felt the government has borrowed
a lot of money in the past ten fifteen
years and spend it on tax cuts for the
rich which is the most idiotic idea you
know because it is not fundamentally
productive but what you're describing is
the problem that we already had which
was this rising inequality and cope it
is actually exacerbating it
it's excise abating on three levels the
gap between the richest countries in the
world and the poorest is going to expand
for the reasons we described the gap
between the biggest companies of world
and the small mom and pops is going to
expand because in this digital world
what's happened is you've had a flight
to date digital a flight to size a
flight to security you know
all of which mean as on gets bigger and
the small mom-and-pop gets smaller
Google gets bigger you know all these
big platforms get bigger and bigger and
even in the the non tech world you're
gonna see that same thing happen the
biggest companies will be able to borrow
and much cheaper rates them and then
finally for people the the Cobra divide
is kind of a class divide I mean who can
work from home it's digital workers
service workers you know consultants
people like you and me who can't work
from home it's people who work with the
hands people who are you know generally
have lower paying jobs lower status in
many ways unfortunately not now I'm not
saying it's the right thing but the
reality is that that device again
expands so you know how do you solve it
look I tend to think that the better
solution and universal basic income is a
massive expansion of the many programs
we have that would achieve something
very similar the my favorite program in
the federal government is the most
difficult to explain and it's one of my
theory is that's why it doesn't it
doesn't do well because nobody
understands it it's called the Earned
Income Tax Credit and basically what it
is as the government says if you work we
are going to make sure that you will
never below the poverty line we're going
to pick an arbitrary number and say you
work the but the for whatever reason the
private sector does not pay you enough
to cross this line we will top it up the
great thing about that is it
incentivizes work it keeps the private
sector life it doesn't distort prices
only you know the way that minimum wages
do have that effect you create a minimum
wage and there is some general
destruction because there are low you
know low level entry jobs that won't be
available this does none of that it's
more effective it's a program that you
know frankly Milton Friedman and Bernie
Sanders both like and yet it's hard to
expand which it's sort of complicated
it's easier to explain minimum wage so
if you could take a program like that
and double or triple it in size if you
could take food stamps you know if you
could take Medicaid and things like that
and just
I mean I think the key should be to make
it so that Americans are confronting a
changing world with with many many
different forces befitting them but they
don't have to go into it naked they
don't have to go into it unarmed they
can have the security of health care
they can have the security of good
nutrition for programs they can have the
security of retraining you know if you
give them all that then they can handle
a world like this but if you don't give
them that then I think you make it very
difficult and the problems with you know
universal basic income obvious it's a
question of whether you D incentivize
work you you destroy the market a lot a
lot of what it does I think doesn't
address one of the core problems that
we're going to face in the world going
forward which is it's not just that
people need money they need they need
something to do they need a calling they
need the dignity of work they need the
sense of status that that gives you I
think honestly particularly for men a
lot of men derive their sense of Worth
from things like that and women are more
complex I think that they because
they've always had the reality of being
you know mothers and and true and care
take because there is a they frankly
have a more sophisticated understanding
of internal network internal Worth which
is a little more socially grounded maybe
it's a contra construct maybe we should
move away from it but the truth is
that's where we are now and I think that
you know you put two or three million
truck drivers out of work because it
found self-driving cars and just saying
then here's a handout I don't think
you've solved the problem yeah it's good
point and I like the earning in crow or
income tax credit as I mean I guess one
way to view is just negative taxes you
know right now you imagine I know the
first X dollars is not taxed in every
increment above that from say twenty to
thirty thousand is taxed at 10% you know
that first bracket is essentially
negative you get paid the government
gives you money it's exactly exactly
nobody I agree makes makes a lot of
sense
so I mean a lot of questions here
actually I mean you know one of them you
know Dan companion on Facebook maybe
we'll end with this you know is money
just an abstract mechanism well I guess
I'll change that into a slightly
different question people ask about
financial form what we should do if they
had shot on the money is yes the the but
I guess one question we talked a lot
about what the Fed can do in the US
what's the negative of what's the
potential limiter on it inflation is it
something else and then you know just to
finish up you know what how do you think
the world is going to be in two or three
years or how do you think it should be
yeah so the limiting effect for central
bank is usually takes it takes two forms
one is you have a few your currency
collapses and second you get the
hyperinflation and the two are linked
and the basic idea is simple which is if
people think you're managing your
affairs really responsibly if you have
debts that you clearly can't pay
basically people start fleeing your
currency they start flee you know nobody
wants to buy your government bonds and
things like that I think the u.s. is far
far away from that scenario you know the
end of the day the taxing potential of
the United States government is enormous
I mean just to give one simple example
in the United States on average has 8%
sales taxes right Europe on average has
25% sales taxes so I'm not saying it's
going to happen but one saying is in
extremis if the United States government
had to find a way to make money it's
it's very easy to imagine doubling the
sales tax it's very easy to imagine you
know moderate rises in income tax for
the middle class and you're talking
about getting huge amounts of money
obviously for the wealthy you can do a
wealth tax I mean again I'm not saying
these things are all good but the United
States is not in a situation where you
would say yourself oh my god they've got
these big budgets and there's no way
they could ever pay this back that's
just not where we are so I think you
know my feeling is the focus should more
be on what are you spending it on
taking another trillion dollars out it
would be great to spend it on
infrastructure frankly that's all the
people you'd employ are exactly the kind
of people we've been talking about who
are having challenges right people who
work with their hands people without
college degrees people who maybe don't
work in big cities you know there's
there's a huge double whammy here which
is you you help the economy by creating
greater more efficient transportation
communication but you also help these
people have really interesting jobs with
dignity and some stuff the the the small
question of where will be two or three
years from now um I think that you know
the there's a part of me that feels like
it's easy to exaggerate the degree to
which you know there will be change I
mean after the influence of 1918 after
all don't forget we had the net the next
big thing that happened in America was
called the Jazz Age the roaring 20s so
you know people got back to to
restaurants and in fact they went back
so fast that even though prohibition was
you know you had prohibition in place
alcohol was illegal you still had the
Jazz Age you still had the Roaring
Twenties so people obviously would kind
of you could even argue they were
desperate to congregate they were
desperate together so I've never bought
the idea that what you're going to see
is a kind of you know the kind of
replacement of life with digital life I
think you would see some level of it but
you're also going to see an enormous
amount of of social Mel Aristotle said
man is a social and political animal and
I think that's very true
but I do think you're going to see the
acceleration of a lot of these trends
that are already in place you know the
further digitization of life I think
that every every big company is going to
ask we work may have failed but every
company will become we work by which I
mean every company is going to say why
do you need to come in to the to the
office 9:00 to 5:00 I remember in your
book you talk about how the the school
is a kind of is an outgrowth of the 19th
century factory marvel where you know
everybody gets at one place you throw
information at them they get through the
conveyor belt by the time they're 80
there when away the modern office is
very similar why does everybody need to
be in the same place at the same time
why do they need to work the same hours
much much more efficient probably would
be a system where people come and go is
the one that still be an office I think
there's still an enormous importance of
real-life meetings but some people come
in three days a week some people come in
- some people come in five you know we
varies week to week maybe you don't need
a personal space that is your desk and
your you know that that's a very
inefficient way to use assets if you
think about it why not have the we work
formula well you know these are all
shared they are used by everyone maybe
everyone has a personal closet or locker
or something like that will you keep
some of your stuff when you're there you
use it when you sum everything is up in
the cloud anyway so why do you need and
if you do that and you reduce office
demand by 25% that's a huge impact on
the way orbán life changes so I think
that's just one example I think those
are the kind of changes you're going to
see that are the most important from a
day to day life the biggest change
that's going to happen that impacts the
kind of world we live in is are you
going to see an acceleration of
nationalism and in particular an
acceleration of the us-china conflict
because if you look forward and saviors
of their two possible models one way
this pandemic which is global in nature
brings us together to realize you know
we kind of need a better of w-h-o we
need by that we need we knew one was
better resourced better staffed and
actually has the power to tell countries
you know to push back against countries
which the waa sure does not have whether
it's against China or the US and those
rules were written by the US because we
don't want the whu-oh telling us you're
not doing a good job on this or that or
do we go down the path of cold war to
where this whole thing becomes really
fundamentally about a corner to our
geopolitical right geopolitical
geo-economic geo technological struggle
between the United States ila which
would be completely new because it is
between the two biggest economies in the
world you know mean u.s. and 1950 was 50
percent of global GDP the Soviet Union
was
well China and the US will be pure
competitiveness and that is a whole new
world and a very dangerous world and a
divided world and so which one of those
we live and I think is a big big
question well no it was freeze you've
given us a lot to talk about and
hopefully you've enjoyed you know you're
in your day job I know you get to write
and and and on a lot of layers but you
know on TV you're always asking folks
questions and I even when I see you I
know that there's a lot in your head
where needs to go and I think for anyone
who's watching this I think has a new
appreciation for for Reid's depth and
breadth of knowledge in all things so I
learn every I learned something every
time we chat so thank you so much for
Reid for joining us
oh it's my pleasure I'm a huge fan of
Khan Academy I would only reiterate the
point you made what you've done is
really revolutionary it is a non-profit
and anyone who's listening and should
realize that if you think about kind of
bang for your buck if you think about
how much of an impact you can have on
helping people if you believe that
education makes a difference this is the
the best way to scale it so when you're
done with this donate some money I tell
you what I'll do the same so you guys
have to follow me know if Reid's been
very kind he's helped us over the years
and and free that I definitely drew you
as family I tell everyone for those who
are not watching we once set to our
families we went to the same conference
and both of us dragged our whole
families along so they put us in the
same house together and I woke up one
morning and you're you were feeding my
you're feeding Imran cereal so anyone
who's who's fed my son cereal in the
morning I consider family so so thank
you so much for great pleasure all best
well thanks everyone for joining hope
hope you enjoyed that conversation as I
said every time I talk to free you know
you can kind of talk about anything and
everything and he's got unusual depth
and insight
so hopefully you enjoyed that and I look
forward to seeing everyone tomorrow
we're going to have actually a Khan
Academy board member James mineka who's
also the head of the McKinsey Global
Institute he's done a lot of work on the
future of work
learning obviously one of our board
members and you know obviously will talk
a lot about what's going on in the world
generally so look forward to seeing all
of y'all noon pacific 3:00 p.m. Eastern
tomorrow
you